Marine biology is a
very unique opportunity
for the students.
They're immersed in the subject,
living and working together.
It is a summer course.
One day represents
essentially a week of work
in a typical semester.
The day to day schedule is pretty intense.
Lectures begin at 8AM,
and then after lecture
they head out to their research site.
And depending on what week we are in
they'll be doing different
activities at the research site.
- And then we usually have
some type of excursion
on the boat.
So that involves scuba
diving or snorkeling.
We come back and we usually
have a two hour break,
and then we have four to
five hours of lab at night.
There's something about
living with a smaller group,
studying the same material,
and going on the same
excursions, doing things together
that just is much more
fun than in a classroom.
It makes biology a lot more
real and a lot more interesting.
- We went scuba diving at Sombrero Reef.
It was amazing.
So it was cool to be on
my own and just explore,
see all the fish and all the colors,
and explore the caves that
the eels were hiding in.
It was just a great experience.
- I think it's very important
that a student find out
what they're passionate
about and pursue it.
And as many opportunities
as they have to find out
what their passion is or
isn't is a good thing.
- I am starting a Masters program
at the University of Delaware in the fall
studying microbial ecology.
This trip definitely made me more sure
that I was doing what
I really wanted to do.
It has a pretty strong research component,
and I really liked that.
And then just kind of working
through that whole process
was pretty valuable in the decision
to go to grad school for biology.
- My plan after I graduated
was to work in an aquarium.
And I just realised after this trip
that's actually what I really want to do.
- [Anthony] And regardless of major,
it's just a unique experience.
- I'm double majoring
in economics and German.
I decided to come on this trip
because I never really
experienced the bio side
of Hillsdale, and I
though this is more fun
and more intensive than Bio 101
but I don't have the distraction
of any other classes.
- [Anthony] Well, I wanted
to make something meaningful,
more than just teaching techniques.
It is such a unique experience.